الاحساس بزوال الاشياء هو الانسان لديه
قدره قدره معينه
يرسم او يعمل قطعه مسيئيه او يكتب نص ادبي
او يصور يعني اهم وسيله هي التصوير
المباشر للامكنه التي قد لا تراها مره
اخرى يعني انا هذا القصد انه هو الكتابي
احيانا عم بحكي عن الكتابه عن الامكنه هي
تسعى لتخليص الامكنه من النسيان في نفس
الوقت اظن انه
الاهم من حمايه الامكنه من النسيان هو
جعلها ماده محيه بالكتابه
والا فان كل شيء
لابد ان ينال نصيبه من النسيان
وانا الروايه التي نشرتها في بدايه
التسعينات عن عن القريه لم تكن بهدف توثيق
لهذه القريه
وتخليدها في في صوره
معينه من خلال روايه جنوب الروح اسمها
ولكن كيف عاشت هذه القريه
كيف عاشت الشخصيات في هذه القريه كيف كانت
تعيش ماذا كانت تنتج من من خيال
ومن قيام جماليه
وكيف ان هذه القريه التي نتجت من هجره
سرعان ما تبددت في هجرات اخرى
واصبح المكان الذي كان اهلا بالسكان وهكذا
اصبحت فارغ اليوم
في هذا
المرور من الانبثاق الى الانطفاء
هناك حياه
لن استطيع
انقاذها من الفناء بالكتابه ولكن
الكتابه
تجعلني في تصالح ما عدا الفناء جميل جميل
نعم